in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast we have a very
very special name do you want to go by
your actual name or your performer name
I guess my performer and real name not a
lot no oh then we'll keep it performer
then mystery baby
we have zet do you say Zeta or Zetas I
say Dana what do other people say they
call is that it they call it both in
your last name is Zhang Jiang okay I
it's supposed to be sung because that's
a profit away but no one can pronounce
it it so I just kind of like
Americanized it so you just call the
sang I just called a Zeta thing you know
the weird thing is I think like we're so
I think we're a little more progressive
now I'm pretty sure people could
pronounce jean like it's not very
[ __ ] difficult it's not that's true
but then it kind of ruins my moniker
wait what's your moniker Zeta thing
brings the bang okay well you could be
Zetas on get some dong there you go some
new [ __ ] right there for you baby that's
cool actually just so I actually just
met Zeta yesterday when we were training
you trade with Nick before yes uh well
my friends Yoshi you know Yoshi he
actually brought me over to the gym and
I met Nick and everyone else how did you
know she he found me on an article on
neck next shark
oh my buddy Betty does a next chart oh
no way yes okay uh oh okay yeah I'm all
world yeah what a small world
yeah so they did an article about me for
wrestling when I was in WWE and then
when I was out in China and all that so
yo she saw me on there and then he
followed me and then it turns out we
ended up having a bunch of mutual
friends
oh my current stunt coach is friends
with Yoshi and they were on set together
and trained together sometimes Yoko so I
didn't know this until I found out
yesterday because I was just looking
your [ __ ] up I was like okay what the
[ __ ] this is kill dude you were the
first female Asian American to be signed
to the WWE
signed in the WWE 2017 oh [ __ ] that
wasn't long ago no not that long ago how
the [ __ ] did that happen like how did
you even get into wrestling in the first
place
okay so what's crazy is I'd never
thought I would end up in Pro Wrestling
I watched as a kid and I thought the
only way you would get in is if you were
a Olympic wrestler but at the very least
one state championships for college
wrestling and then how are a lot of
wrestlers in the WWE former actual
wrestlers back in the day I know Kurt
Angle was an Olympic medalist which was
very interesting yeah but now it's
different now there's wrestling school
like pro wrestling schools where people
just that's all they train yeah and it's
like the thing but I didn't even know
that existed and so I ended up going the
MMA route so I went in did MMA I was
like oh there's no chance for me I've
always been interested in martial arts
and grappling and like wrestling yeah in
the ground game so I ended up doing
Brazilian jiu-jitsu which lets MMA and
through my MMA is how I ended up getting
recruited got a chance to do a tryout
for WWE and got through and bam not fine
how long did you do MMA for about 10
years 10 years yeah you just brushed by
like it was like a couple of [ __ ]
days you did over ten [ __ ] years yeah
well I mean walk first of all that's
[ __ ] oh I don't even know if a lot of
people even knew about MMA ten years ago
I know I did it before it got popular
and I did you just sue B forgot popular
and now everyone their moms doing it
yeah it's kind of crazy because like ten
years ago I mean I think honestly the
the person who blew up the sport the
most was Conor McGregor like an after
McGregor came on the scene everybody
knew about MMA cuz I mean everybody knew
about UFC and then Bellator was talked
about here and there but not a lot of
people knew about like one Fc and a lot
of these other small promotions like
lights out and stuff like that but when
Conor McGregor came on the scene he just
kind of put a lot of light on it because
nobody was promoting MMA like like the
WWE does exactly and then karna McGregor
kind of brought that WWE element to it
that shit-talking there's this backstory
that starts to develop and then you see
UFC's platform start to develop kind of
like WWE where they have if you see all
the promos for the UFC prior to like the
whole Conor McGregor thing and this is
just my opinion it wasn't like how it is
now there's this whole like good guy
versus bad guy type of thing just like
the WWE like recently there was a Camaro
Iseman and called becoming ttan and
Kemara huisman was the good guy and then
called becoming Tain's the bad guy and
they started building it up in this type
of weird way but it really gives people
to buy tickets I think like okay so
there's a little history with UFC and
WWE they kind of used to not like each
other but I think in recently they have
a you know they're kind of okay with
each other secretly so they're kind of
working together I can't say they're
really working together but they're kind
of cool with each other in certain ways
so I'm actually seeing a trend where all
the UFC fighters and UFC is being more
like WWE and WWE is being more like UFC
oh really yes in terms of like they're
incorporating like real fight moves yes
they're incorporating real fight moves
therefore hiring people with MMA
backgrounds so right before me I was the
second mm a girl they hired but the
first one was actually my friend Dario
Bernardo she is from a Muay Thai
background she's actually out of here
now she goes by Sonya Deville on TV I
think I don't know if she owns raw or
Smackdown she switched between two
brands but either way we actually
trained together so oh yeah we trained
together real right like you know in MMA
yeah or I would say ma like wrestling
yeah so amateur wrestling and her gym is
systems over in like Hawthorne and I
used to train over at black house I'm at
me alright yeah so she actually came
over and trained with me a my wrestling
coach Kenny Johnson and I was like oh my
gosh I finally get a girl to train with
because I never have girls to train with
and we're training together all the time
for like a month and then she disappears
I was like what
where's my training partner like I
finally get a girl and she disappears on
me then eight months later like I find
out she's working for WWE as a pro
wrestler and I see her during my tryout
and I was like wow what a crazy world
and so she's doing really well
and I realized now you know back then
with WWE everyone has the like there's
never gonna be another Undertaker you
know people have real names now
now they purposely have names where they
got first name and last name and it's
the make more real yes yeah so there's
no one else doesn't mean named
Undertaker anymore
or like anything too crazy they're
giving everyone like normal names why is
that is it they want it to be more
realistic they don't want to go the
cheesy like whatever route because they
feel like everyone wants realism so they
want it as real as possible really but
yeah that was the [ __ ] I love the name
Undertaker came the rock Stone Cold
Steve Austin are you [ __ ] kidding me
where the [ __ ] would you take that away
that's what get insane like they they
found it better that people had real
[ __ ] names yeah really yeah everyone
has a first name and last name well
nobody wants a [ __ ] action figure of
David so like you know it was a [ __ ]
regular last name what the hell like I
thought they were like that Razor Ramon
like you know the like come on man a
Hulk Hogan like I loved all these
[ __ ] names
that's so weird I would think that
actually I don't know the demographic or
the age demographic for the WWE law was
PG and it was a family show they
targeted it like they would for Disney
they wanted you to bring your kids
because that is merchandise sales all of
them want to buy all these action
figures but now they recently changed a
pg-13 because of AE W all you leave
wrestling they're competing directly
against each other so aw is pretty much
like the WCW back in a day where they're
fighting each other yeah for the spot so
now they're because a double use more
pg-13 WWE had a switch at a pg-13 so now
you're seeing people making out on TV or
like zoom up on butt cheeks yeah that's
[ __ ] crazy okay now I remember when I
was a kid like every now and then
there'd be like some random like nip
slip or some [ __ ] and they're like [ __ ]
right yeah but that was like some random
[ __ ] you know what I mean and though I
remember somebody who was who really
popped off I think even after she left
that be Stacy Keibler uh-huh she was
huge and yeah she moved on for their own
personal stuff too but she was [ __ ]
pretty as [ __ ] and then those people
like Sabol there was yes people don't
[ __ ] know man like I love that [ __ ]
and there was the there was the girl
that was always attached to the Hardy
Boys what was her name she had red money
here no I'm not the person to ask
because honestly when I watched it I was
so young yeah and then finally and then
I went into the MMA thing so I had this
huge gap yeah before I got back into
honestly and get back into it until two
and a half months before my tryout
that's [ __ ] crazy
and what's crazy is I honestly didn't
know that it was I didn't really know if
it was a work or not until before my
giant oh really
what the [ __ ] I don't no one believes me
so I mean it kind of okay so I watched
it from four years old
mm-hmm and at four years old even though
I was born in the US I didn't even know
English yet I didn't learn English
what yeah because like my parents were
busy they were running a restaurant I
was being taken care of by my grandma
yeah my grandma only spoke Mandarin and
she took care of me growing up and she
liked watching wrestling so I wash it
with her she got me into it so weird so
[ __ ] odd she's just like oh yeah
[ __ ] slam him already man she was it
was crazy as she was her favorite was
Hulk Hogan so she was all about Hulk
Hogan yeah and um I watched it and
didn't learn English I didn't start
learning English until I was like six
even though I was born in the US I had
trouble like were you and yourself it no
because I was born in the you
I was technically not considered foreign
so I wasn't required to take ESL what
the hell yeah so I never took ASL I
never learn English properly it was just
from being around it and slowly I picked
it up
yeah but basically I washed it until I
was like 12 and then when my grant
grandma got Alzheimer's and start
getting like really sick I stopped
watching it because it was like our
thing yeah so I completely stopped when
she passed away when I was like 15 16
and then in my you know when you watch
something as a kid
whatever you remembered it as that's
what you remember it is yeah yeah so I
just to me I was like oh that's that's
what wrestling is it's a real sport
yeah and the weird thing is I watch pro
wrestling and I even watch college
wrestling at the same time but I watch
more pro wrestling and the funny thing
is I just thought the college wrestling
didn't have a good budget that's why
they couldn't watch you're so funny
oh you're like dude look at these bums
over here their costumes man they only
wear red and blue and that's it bunch of
losers Doozers don't have good lighting
they don't have all with them they're
not hardcore now that's hilarious so I
just thought that's at the lower budget
one and so I was like more drawn over to
WWF at the time and even some WCW we
watched both a back and forth and then
um then I got MMA I went in start with
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu because it was the
closest thing the wrestling and I had an
interest in wrestling I wanted to do it
growing up I never had the confidence
never had the confidence I didn't come
from a sports background so like oh I
can't do it I don't believe I can do it
so I just never did until finally I go
off to college I'm in a really unsafe
City came a across I went there really
naive came across some incidences where
you know I could have gotten gang-raped
and it scared the hell out of me and I'm
just like what kind so what do you mean
so well my first so I'm actually from
born raised and Charles Virginia
Charleston Virginia was actually rate in
2010
it was rated to number one best city 11
on USA Today
it was safe the safest city 11 this
podcast is brought to you by purple my
friends have you had good sleep lately
do you dread going home turning off the
lights and sleeping on that rock of a
piece of do do you call a mattress well
that's because you don't have a purple
mattress my friends and I'm guessing you
know what I'm betting that you're not
having the best night's sleep of your
life and if you do think that you are
just wait till you sleep on a purple
mattress there's rocket science behind
the development of what this mattress is
made out of it's firm and soft at the
same time and it'll feel like nothing
you have ever felt before
I have had my mattress for a while now I
love it it's the best thing that I have
and it's the thing that I look forward
to before I go to sleep and if you have
not have not experienced good sleep my
friends what are you waiting for get on
a purple mattress man it's it's it's
literally so important for you to find
something that you could sleep really
well on sleep is super important to you
I didn't know that I didn't know that
the type of bed that I had before was
keeping me up I just thought that
everybody's bed just went to crap after
a while but let me tell you something I
was corrected purple mattress has saved
my body and my sleep so check this out
you're gonna love purple and right now
my listeners will get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress
that's in addition to the great free
gifts they're offering site-wide just
text brain to eight four eight eight the
only way to get this free pillow is a
text to brain eight four eight eight
eight once again text brain two eight
four eight eight a that's brain be are
AI n two eight four eight eight eight
and then I moved to Richmond Virginia
rated number one murder City for like
four years in a row in like the late 90s
and 2000's and when I went there for
college at VCU it was 2007 and it was
still ranked number four and Richmond is
one of those cities were it's it's small
but there's a lot of people so
everything's tight vicinity and you run
into [ __ ] all the time yeah it's like oh
there's a shooting or stabbing a rape
whatever all like down the street from
you so I went there thinking like oh
it's fine I'm not gonna get nothing's
gonna happen to me I'm in a big city why
would he target me out of all the people
that's here so I freakin go there and my
first Halloween my friend this was
before like GPS oh yeah it was like
before you got that on your phone so my
first Halloween my friend's giving me
directions on the phone and she goes oh
yeah just drive here and stuff I was
like hey am I supposed to take a left or
right and she wasn't sure so she goes
stay there I'm gonna get my friend come
get you but I was already close by like
maybe five minutes so five minutes later
this guy pulls up and he waves his hand
out the window like the sunroof window
he's like follow me and I just took my
head I was like did I just speak to you
on the phone I didn't mention anything
about party and he goes yeah the party's
here follow me and I was like okay this
is the guy I think this is the guy yeah
he pulls up and then I see another car
behind him with four guys in that car I
didn't think anything of it I didn't I
thought it was just a mother a car so I
pull up I end up trapped between the two
cars they lead me down some dark alley
and then they parked their car and
turned all the lights off oh and I'm
sitting there like okay whoa is this the
place and I'm like trying to figure it
out and I was so naive at the time I
didn't think anything of it so and I was
like is this where it's at I call my
friend I'm like hey I think I'm here I
think I'm in the back like where are you
and she keeps looking for me and after
like what felt like five minutes I don't
even know how long it was but it felt
like five full minutes when she was just
like I don't see you like where are you
and I started getting this awkward
feeling or something was wrong and I
remember looking at my rearview mirror
and it was so scary because I just see
the four dudes in the back they're all
slouched like just waiting and the guy
in the car in front he got out and he's
standing three feet away from me
I had my door open my window rolled down
and everything and I was just like is
this where the party's at and he
lied to me he's like yes where the
party's at and I'm just like still
waiting on my friend I don't know what
to say I got this like weird feeling in
my stomach but I didn't know how to get
out the situation yeah and I think it
never really it didn't click in my head
yet I just felt like something was weird
but yeah I just there's nothing clicked
in my head yet until my friend I asked
him three times I was like is this where
the party's at and after the third time
she heard his voice and she goes who's
that
as soon as she said who's that like I
realize this isn't the guy and I started
freaking out I lost my cool and I was
like what the hell what the [ __ ] is this
like not the guy you told me that's
gonna come get me and he's standing
right there so of course he heard me and
then he gets aggressive he gets all up
on my window and he goes what what what
you don't believe me you don't believe
me if you don't believe me go back where
you came from and I was so lucky because
this alleyway was long and narrow it
only fit one card it was like not yeah
I only fit one car but it just so
happened that where I parked the
building like the building kind of
dented in it was like a shorter building
so it was kind of like this okay and uh
where I was it just so happened that
also the car behind me was back just far
enough where I could back out and do
this and get out yeah I guess and I just
shut the door and went and I was so
lucky because he could've easily pulled
me out there's four dudes back there
just waiting for [ __ ] to happen and they
don't gonna rape you dude dude I know
they would have % they were gonna rape
you because it keeps happening like it
almost happened my friend it's happened
to my friend like there's been lots of
stuff that happens in Richmond all the
time because when I was there it's an
open campus so they would send us text
messages whenever there's stuff going on
and literally every single weekend rape
here stabbing here on this street on
this room it was every [ __ ] weekend
it got to a point where it was just so
normal and they even got a thing like
this was a thing at my school where if
you got
robbed or stabbed or hurt anything on
campus the school will pay for your
tuition what yeah it was how much that
should happen yep
we like me and that yeah me and my
friend out there he freaking we got
friends that got held up at gunpoint
very many a bunch of times one guy got
stabbed like there's so many they were
doing that so they because they didn't
want people to find out and then they
would lose like the tendons in their
college because yeah nobody would come
yeah and then it got to a point where
students were trying to shoot themselves
in the foot
I would like next a scruff that my
hair's like listen I've been raped
hey listen dude nobody wait you're like
six foot one like 300 pounds who the
[ __ ] raped you I'll tell you who that it
was a bunch of women a bunch of women
wanted my lumps and they [ __ ] they
just took a titty [ __ ] me that's what
happened like get the [ __ ] out of your
dude that's [ __ ] crazy yeah so that's
what got you to start doing jujitsu yeah
so this scared me so much where I'm like
I need to do something to defend myself
yeah so I wanted to take martial arts
but I didn't know what to take I've
always been interested because I used to
watch all these kung fu movies and [ __ ]
when I was a kid because I had no
friends wait a lot I got bullied my
whole life coming from the East Coast I
was like the one Asian pretty much and
so growing up I always was kind of
attracted to that and then the guy I was
dating at the time he was interested in
watching UFC and he was always
interested in the ground game so we
joined together but I was dating him
before I moved off to college
and so he's two and a half hours away
from where I live and he wouldn't be
able to come up very often but we joined
together and for the two months we only
went twice like I wasn't that serious
into it and I was still very shy I grew
up very shy and just no confidence so I
was
scared to go in there without him I
would never go to training unless he was
there with me and then shortly after his
ass broke up with me
that was pissed yeah I was [ __ ]
pissed I was like you know what I'm
gonna kick his ass the next time I see
him so I went and trained my ass off so
you could beat up a boy that's right
crazy pants I'm like oh yeah he's gonna
break up my ass I'm gonna train so hard
and kick his ass when I see him next so
I ended up training so hard I got the
attentions of all my coaches and then
they ended up taking me under their wing
training me and getting me to do my
first tournament and when I won that
tournament it was life-changing it
changed my life and made me view things
differently I had full confidence in
myself and then I did that then I ended
up getting tricked into my first MMA
fight tricked into an MMA fight how the
[ __ ] does that work out did a single
person that will trick me going to them
and they fight up like this is not
happening to you like hey so you just
saw a key do you like it this looks v
like it's a comedy club in the cage you
know you just come on in you know tell
some jokes oh we start punching in the
face Oh am I doing that bad now my
Joseph my jokes Bobby that bad huh give
me the face well like it's crazy cuz um
yeah I I was doing jujitsu but honestly
the first gym I went to it was not
exactly the best gym what because it was
one of those gyms that they just taught
you just enough to get you to like blue
belt level and then they don't want you
to improve anymore because a lot of
people it was one of the first gyms
around that was started there and it
used to be super legit but what happened
was all the legit people that got really
good they branched off and opened up
their own gyms and became competition so
the owner was like oh you can't be
teaching these people - these people
real jiu-jitsu cuz they're gonna open up
their own gym and become our competition
so they started teaching like [ __ ]
jiu-jitsu and just teaching you just
good enough to fight white belts and
anything more you're kind of like you're
going to lose yeah and so when I
realized the level of skills that's the
I ended up leaving and they also like
tricked me and like lied to me and I was
stuck on this contract but luckily at
this point I had people taking me under
their wings because they saw that I was
very like into it and really oh this
place called world class martial arts
there was a it was under well it was
this Brazilian guide named burrs Roberto
Neary I mean I don't have anything I
can't really say anything bad about him
he wanted to it was because of the owner
the owner told him to not teach people
real jiu-jitsu and that guy ended up
leaving because he was he thought it was
wrong to do that so he told him you
can't teach them good jiu-jitsu you got
to teach them up to blue belt level so
because of that I was like all right I
need a you know I need to leave this
place so I left I ended up going and
following this guy that was teaching at
another gym it was an MMA gym but he
taught jiu-jitsu so I ended up following
him to his gym and started training
there and because I was already paying
for I'm like I might as well training
everything I really didn't care about
anything else
everything was just more so for cardio
and working out but I only cared about
jiu-jitsu but my MMA coach because the
owner was also the MMA coach he would
come up to me every single day and be
like you should fight he should fight
I'm like no I don't want to like I don't
want to fight MMA I was like no no no I
keep telling him no and he was on my ass
like a month and a half non-stop every
single day telling me I need a fight and
finally I got really annoyed one day and
I was just like I'm just gonna tell him
yeah maybe just get him off my back so
one day I'm like okay yeah maybe I'll
think about it
and then the next day he comes to me and
he goes oh hey there's a fight coming up
in three weeks and I was just like okay
first of all three weeks there's no time
for a fight
and he goes oh no pressure you just
train really hard for two weeks and if
you're not feeling up to it you don't
have to do it you back out anytime I was
like okay so I'm training
I'm going hard for a week and a half a
week and a half into it I was like oh
hell no I don't want to do this like I
don't want to do this I don't have this
fight and the girl I had a fight man she
had like three years of striking
experience oh sure and I don't have any
striking yeah I'm just all jujitsu and I
didn't even know wrestling at this time
I only knew jujitsu like traditional
ground jujitsu I didn't really know how
to take downs like yeah the jujitsu I
started with was like the traditional
play off your back defensive jujitsu
definitely not fit for MMA style when
you're supposed to be on the top so I'm
just like hell no I don't even know how
to get this damn girl down so within
these this time I'm like trying to learn
how to strike and all I knew was a jab
cross elbow knee that's all I knew and
um then I'm telling him I'm like I'm
gonna tell my coach I'm not not gonna do
this I go up to him I'm like hey um I
can't talk to you he's like oh yeah and
you talk to you too so they wrote an
article about you in the newspaper and
magazines for your fight next and
blah-dee-blah on this date and I was
just like I was just thinking well [ __ ]
now I can't back out like I just wrote a
whole damn article now I'm like forced
to fight so then my dumb ass because I
don't come from a sports background I
was a shy art girl nerdy stayed at home
and no friends type of girl and now I'm
about to take a damn MMA fight and I
have no sports background and I don't
know like how to properly cut weight I
don't know how to properly lift and oh I
knew how to lift but I don't know like
like the science behind it is yes I am
and so just because I heard other people
talking they're like oh yeah because the
girl I had a fight up away class at the
time I only well I walked around like at
118 121 pounds yeah so I should be
fighting at 115 but even then that is
really light if that's my walk-around
weight that's not much to cut yeah and
so and also so weird thing with Virginia
and the East Coast and even Washington
DC because I fought in Washington DC
though it was Pro rules even though it
wasn't pro but the
were Pro the weigh-ins are the night
before that means people are cutting a
bunch of weight before they fight so
because I'm having a fight at 125 I have
to go up away class people are like oh
yeah just eat a bunch and then you'll
gain muscle especially three weeks that
is no time
you're fine super underweight then yeah
and but the problem with me and my body
is that I can gain weight easy but
problem is I didn't gain good way I just
got fat
I'm just freaking like I went from what
was that I was like 121 122 uh-oh
I was at one yeah 121 122 and within
three weeks I went up to 132 that's
crazy yeah I gained 10 pounds and then I
had to cut down to 126 because it's like
125 by year 1 pound limit so I had to
cut down to 126 and I didn't know how to
at all cuz I've never cut way I don't
have any science behind it and back then
this is like 2009 I got that Waterway
baby I don't know how to and it just so
happens that my weigh-ins that day I was
on my damn period oh hello didn't do I
was bloated I couldn't lose any water
I didn't eat or drink for four days I
could have died yeah I don't know how I
was able to get through that this was
over the summer this was July first my
birthday on my birthday I had to weigh
in on my damn cut weight on my birth
date away and as my fight was July 2nd
and we're driving up to DC from Virginia
and it was a five and a half hour
traffic and that year was a
record-breaking heat wave that summer
godred and 4 degrees we're in this
[ __ ] car and all the windows are
rolled up we're blasting heat wearing
sweat pants and cutting and everyone in
there dips they dips and spit yeah get
out any water but I don't dip I don't do
tobacco so I had a stuck on Jolly
Ranchers all day and spit and my tongue
is like bleeding from sucking on Jolly
Ranchers all day Wow and I'm already
lacking water and my coach made me drink
two tubs of EPs
salt and because I hadn't eaten for four
days nothing came out
because he was trying to get me a
diarrhea yeah yeah but nothing came out
so it just stayed in my body you know
that Salt's thing in my body probably
was not good because then I couldn't
sweat anything out yeah so when I was
cutting away dude I was legit in the Sun
all day with two layers of hoodies two
of with two towels wrapped underneath
Anna like a sweat rap band and two pairs
of socks two pairs of pants jump roping
burpees [ __ ] like knee touches like
non-stop in there working out trying to
sweat it out to the point where my body
wouldn't even sweat anymore where I had
to sleep in a sauna suit I slept in the
sauna suit all night because I didn't
make weight I didn't make weight I was
only I was only 0.6 pounds over I was
only 0.6 pounding you really couldn't
cut because that's how that's pretty
intense cuz I think for me if I'm a
pretty big guy so like if I wanted to
cut like five pounds in a day I could do
it I could just literally not eat sweat
run like ten miles in a [ __ ] sauna
suit and then I'll cut that five pounds
like that I think the most I can cut in
a day maybe like two pounds but no my
body just does not it yeah I can't it's
hard because like I mean when you were
probably doing and you're doing it with
the people that you're doing it with
these people aren't really well versed
and how like the body works yeah there's
like you know there's people and looking
the UFC now when they get their money
they get their paychecks they have a
whole team around them and this team
really understands nutrition they
understand dieting they understand how
to cut weight there's like I forgot who
it was but there's this guy that's very
very good at cutting way he's like this
specialist but he he gets people to cut
weight like nothing not nothing but he
understands the science behind behind it
and how like the body retains water and
stuff like that yep and so I'm pretty
sure you didn't have that and so there's
trying to get now sweat that's what he
just had you you eat Epsom salt yeah and
on top of that like oh I was also
drinking clay
I was drinking white been a night
whatever clay because there's this one
thing that's supposed to like take out
is sort of as trap any type of like
stuff inside and poop it out but the
problem is I had no food they
to help push it out so it was just
sitting in there yeah and plus back then
they don't know about girls fighting
there was no girls fighting so there was
no science behind how a girl would cut
way especially during her period oh yeah
yeah oh there was all those factors
involved in hormones and everything else
I'm like just having the toughest time
and did she take the fight even though
you're like she did okay because like so
I asked her I was like hey so as a girl
my dumb ass I went to her went to my
opponent and her coach I was like hey so
you know you know as a girl you know I'm
on my period I'm only 0.6 pounds over is
a cool if we find out a catchweight
and of course his her coach is like nope
you got to cut the weight to get me
weaker yeah so that's why I ended up at
that time I was only three days of no
food no water which is still a lot so I
ended up having cut weight up to two
hours before my fight well [ __ ] go to
the next day didn't freakin eat anything
and finally I make weight and we end up
fighting and Judah was the craziest
experience in my life like I felt like I
was in a movie because I forgot what
movie it was there was that one movie
with uh Jet Li Oh Joe Jet Li where right
before every fight scene everything goes
into tunnel vision and everything
slow-mo and I remember watching that
movie on my own [ __ ] [ __ ] that
doesn't happen when you fight due to
legit that [ __ ] happens like to
Tootsie it looked like it was in a movie
I don't even know how I won that fight
because skill-wise she was better than
me like way twice I like everything she
was she supposed to win the fight but
because of I was just pissed at the fact
like I'm like I'm not gonna lose because
I did not cut weight and come all the
way up here didn't eat or drink water
for four days to come up here to lose a
damn fight how did you win the fight
three rounds of you know a unanimous
decision
oh really 27 30 27 30 27 years I was
quarter yeah so I stood up or stand up I
didn't even get any takedowns because I
did
no wrestling I learned all my striking
and wrestling in three weeks
oh [ __ ] so I couldn't take her down in
the problem was she knew I was a ground
girl she knew I was a jiu-jitsu girl so
she stuffed all my takedowns and so I
never got her to the ground and I ended
up having a stand with her all three
grounds and the only
oh yeah I was [ __ ] crazy I don't even
know how I did it I was just I think it
was the adrenaline because the
adrenaline got me so focused at a point
where I saw all her punches coming
eight seconds before it happened it felt
like eight seconds because I remember
there was one point where I elbowed her
no I punched her a chapter in the face
and broke her nose and she was bleeding
and when she was bleeding I felt bad I
actually felt bowels like I thought to
myself I was like damn her nose is
broken I'm like maybe I shall let her
punch me I feel really bad I don't have
any of that [ __ ] punch the faces like
you should have kept your hands up yeah
I don't know I was like because my first
fight I felt bad like I'm not a I I
never decided to get into fighting I
wanted it I self-defense like I'm not a
I can't believe got peer pressure into
finding that no there's no such thing as
peer pressure for me and they said they
put my [ __ ] name on the newspaper I'm
like well I guess everybody just wasted
a bunch of [ __ ] ink cuz I'm not
showing up Bay Bay and I would just move
on from it that's [ __ ] crazy I can't
get peer pressure in that [ __ ]
especially now just because like how
like well you know what to be honest
with you like I've I've been to a few
smokers before and you know it's kind of
a toss-up because some people are dope
and some people are just really [ __ ]
bad exact just a matter of luck it's
like who are you gonna get to fight in
this round right because there's even
like like the Muay Thai point system
[ __ ] right exactly like like I've you
met Alex Ryan our buddy Alex Alex did a
PK B match and you know I've seen PK B's
where you know it's supposed to be an
amateur point system thing right so
you're not supposed to throw like full
clip and they do it based on points if
it gets too crazy be kind of break it up
and split it up that [ __ ] was not the
case for Alex's it was a PKB thing but
they were throwing full [ __ ] clip and
then there was no the ref
stepping or stopping at all so I was
like oh man this is all the [ __ ] wash
now you never know what's gonna [ __ ]
happen because believe what I saw Alexes
match I was like hey I'm dude this is
just a full-on amateur match dude this
is not a PKB match cuz they just were
just throwing a hundred percent it was
[ __ ] crazy
so I feel like nowadays like it's it's
so hard because like you just don't know
some if you're gonna get the guy that
trains six times a week or gonna get the
guy that trains like a couple n thinks
he's a fighter you know
so you might get little it's like that
because I know usually it makes the
promotion look bad if the matchmaking is
not welcome what clothes
well pique bees are just burners so
they're not okay there's no like
promotion there's not like a lights-out
type of thing or it's not like one of
those like small consider like small
like UFC MMA fighting rings like this is
like smokers v PK B's I'm not I'm not
sure how they're sanctioned but there's
a ref there it's it's an open match
space so it's not within a ring so these
this is like multi point system [ __ ]
and so they have had year they have shin
guards or whatever because it's still an
amateur match but they do it based on
points and you're not supposed to get
knocked out I think like if you knock
the person out you lose see I I think
yeah I mean that's kind of weird they
but I understand also because I think
it's different when they add the element
of protection because if there is if you
don't have headgear and anything to
protect you then it should be mashed up
more evenly yeah at least because if you
have something for protection because
Virginia it was so not regulated same
with DC in the East Coast during that
time it was all pro rules I could elbow
I can need to the face everything
amateur yeah that's [ __ ] great
everything was allowed with no
protection we didn't have anything
no shin pads nothing yikes yeah like I
look back on it I'm like that's stupid
and I'm like how many how many fights
did you do after that I three so I had
four total and so you just kept
continuing I would have stopped I'm like
I won I'm good if I went one match I'm
done well I ended up liking it and I
ended up wanting to do it as a career oh
whoa I like really seriously wanted to
pursue it have you ever lost no oh you
never lost so you just kept winning
yeah I'm winning four fights for MMA and
for my jiu-jitsu I had 18 matches and I
won 16 out of 18 that's [ __ ] crazy
but yours but you know we're here yeah
you have so many [ __ ] injuries now
and that's that's not even from the
fighting that's from [ __ ] pro
wrestling well I think the reason why
I'm so prone to injury now is because of
my overtraining in MMA because I used to
Train
ridiculous like like I'm talking I'm not
even exaggerating 15 half hours was my
most a day [ __ ] crazy yeah but my
average was eight hours a day of
straight training and I did that for
years and I never stretched never did
rehab for sure why you got hurt though
yeah because my body I mean there's this
huge like science behind I mean I'm
saying like how much like fight science
has evolved like one of the guys that I
love following is kind of frost a hobby
like frost ahadees GS B's coach right
yeah and he always talks about people
who who they don't really optimize their
training and it's that old fashioned
thing of just going ham yeah that's what
was brought up on it was stupid 8 to 15
hours a day no rest not thinking about
nutrition stretching flexibility
mobility like functional fitness and so
like what I love about like what frost
talks about she talks about like a lot
of like optimized training so when you
should train how you should train you
know you're not supposed to go ham like
2424 [ __ ] 7 there's like a certain
amount of hours that you should train
and you should be training at about like
50 to 60%
you know yep if you're pushing weight
you shouldn't be going yet at your max
everyday you know you basically you know
you overload your nervous system there's
all this like science behind it that's
developed and it's because people like
you started this way that's crazy
it sucks because back then it was that
like tough-guy mentality cuz during my
first fight I had her tore my ACL my ACL
tour before that and I fought my first
fight on a torn ACL and my knee popped
up during my fight and I had to pop it
back in during the fight bug yeah and
then my second fight I tore my shoulder
my shoulder was falling out and had a
fight with a shoulder out of socket and
just keep it packed in so it was just
like stupid stuff it's like was it your
jab or was it your cross it was my job
shoulder oh [ __ ] yeah and the thing is I
always lead with a jab and stuff so I
mean it was super [ __ ] up but how did
you win that fight without you without
one of your heart um I ended up getting
rear naked choke oh [ __ ] yeah
so that one by that time I you know I
learned some wrestling a little bit more
and I knew how to take people down but
my first fight
you know just way too new didn't know
anything and yeah I but I was stubborn
you know I'm stubborn and I think the
way I won that fight was because she
punched me thinking I would go down but
I just keep coming forward I just took
the punch I just kept going I were just
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] is not gonna
like like I remember when she hit me I
didn't even feel pain because adrenaline
but I heard the thud of my skull oh [ __ ]
yeah I heard my stall go doom yeah I was
like this [ __ ] just hit me yeah because
I when I went in it was so weird because
I seen people fight and every time
before they fight they get they hide
themselves up it was like yeah yeah yeah
and they're just like oh and they're
coming out and I felt nothing yeah I
felt nothing
my coaches were actually concerned and
they forced me to go and warm up and do
something and get hype I didn't feel
hype I just walked out on normal and I
was just chilling I walked in the cage I
was like alright I'm waiting for me to
feel hype I don't feel anything the door
closes I was like well alright we're in
here now ding ding ding and I still feel
nothing she runs and charges at me and
punches me in the head and then that's
when everything came in and I got I was
like this [ __ ] just punched me yeah and
then I was like well [ __ ] this and then
we started like fighting and stuff but
yeah I think the only reason is she
thought I would go down and I just
didn't because I don't know I was like
[ __ ] like [ __ ] this I'm not trying to
lose I think like some people too like
they kind of they get revved up once
that contact happens because even Nick
was talking about like when he would
fight he's a slow starter yeah I think
Nick had like 5 or 6 amateur matches and
then he was a slow starter so he was
like you know it's all good in gravy he
feels out and once somebody starts like
you know clipping him and that's when he
gets like oh [ __ ] now it's on so there's
I think like these people who fight
differently but it's interesting because
like nobody knows what it's like to
fight until you sock in the face
now it's all theory you know yeah even
like light sparring's all theory because
you know you're throwing it about like
30% 30% but then when you have when like
there's two things that happen right
which I don't think people understand
it's like number one what it feels like
to get rocked when you get hit mm-hmm
feels completely different and number
two is what how exhausted you get when
you're throwing full clip so yeah that's
the part it's like you think it's it's
tiring to hit a bag try try try throwing
and a hundred percent and missing does
that's why these people get tired
they're throwing in its when people have
great head movement they're ducking
they're slipping they're rolling and
these guys are tossing the throwing it a
hundred percent and then you see like in
boxing they're exhausted after so you're
like why is defense so important well
those people who throw at a hundred
percent in the mist they're exhausted
yeah that's why I think it's super
important for people whoever watches
like UFC or or they watch any type of
like competitive martial arts that's
actually the reason why I started going
back into training and I hit up Nick and
I just by chance met him and we decided
to train together and was because I
wanted to know the sport a little more
because every time I watched the UFC I
can only understand it up to a certain
point right it's because I don't know
what it's like to be exhausted like that
I don't know what it's like to exchange
like that I don't understand the science
behind kickboxing and I don't understand
the science behind like just suing the
ground game yourself so when I started
training with Nick then the sport became
more fun because now I'm like no I could
see this I could see why people because
before like I feel like when I was
watching it sometimes I would get upset
at fighters if they're doing certain
things but now that I've been in a
training situation I'm like oh no I know
why they're [ __ ] up
he's [ __ ] tired yeah he's gassed out
you know I mean so like a great example
is like I got a buddy named Andre sukham
taht he used to be he's a former UFC
fighter
shoutout to Andre I followed him when he
was at a different promotion and then
when he got into the UFC so he fought
this guy named Sean O'Malley now in this
fight and it was kind of getting lit up
a little bit Andre is a very very very
[ __ ] tough guy I don't think he's
ever been knocked out ever or tko'ed or
anything everything went to either
decision he lost or he won
Andre basically what happens is Sean
O'Malley I think what happened was Andre
had a high guard he did a high kick and
then Sean O'Malley broke either his foot
he broke his foot or his ankle and then
Andre everybody was freaking out
because when Andre was in that match
what was happening was his foot was out
all he had to do was stand up attack his
leg or something and the ref would have
called it off because Shawn couldn't
stand and this was like in the last like
minute of the round or so Andra decides
to go for a takedown instead which now
it doesn't really matter whether his
angels hurt enough cuz the refs not
gonna call it off because it's on his
back and so Andre was losing the fight
up into that point but if the ref saw
that his foot was broken and Shawn
couldn't stand on it they would have
caught the match and honey when I got
the W but Andre went for the takedown he
was resting and people were screaming
like what the [ __ ] are you doing like
why did you take him down and so but
because I've been training I kind of saw
him because he was getting hit in the
head a lot here he had television he was
he was like on the verge of blacking out
so whatever his coaches were screaming
at him like yo like don't go for the
takedown
go for the strikes go for it like he
couldn't hear that [ __ ] he was over he
was already just out on his feet I mean
so when people watch a match like that
and I've read all the comments and stuff
that people were saying like yo that was
a dumb move but it's like if you've
never trained right like if you've never
been hit in your [ __ ] head and I
haven't gone three rounds with somebody
you don't know what that fighters going
through I know like when other fighters
say that [ __ ] they can maybe they have a
better opinion on it because they said
like oh I wouldn't have done that no
matter what maybe they do but from my
perspective I saw a guy who was you know
the guy got struck in his head a lot and
he was kind of dazed so I'm sure he
couldn't hear anything and I asked him
and that was the case he goes dude at
that point bro he was like I was I was
just trying to survive so yeah he was
lighting me up and what I just couldn't
hear my coaches my ears are ringing I
couldn't hear [ __ ] and so that's what's
happening so that's like that
perspective of like people who don't
train and they have a harsh opinion
about a sport that they don't know
anything about you know exactly that's
oh that's the thing that I actually hate
the most when when I'm seeing people as
a fan I guess watching it and they're
screaming and getting angry about the
fact they're like why the hell didn't
you do this well it's like it's a lot
more complicated than that yeah and it's
like unless you've done it and you
really know how it's like and even if
you've done it it's it's different in a
fighh situation yeah and on top of that
every fighters different their mentality
goes into it differently oh I think that
mentality part is huge because there's
people who who I love in the USC who uh
there's like I feel like it's a game of
inches you know what I mean because
they're all a part of great camps
they're all great fighters um but
there's just something missing in their
game but just like small things that put
them above somebody else yes like one of
my favorite fighters in the UFC right
now which he was like kind of on a
losing streak he was going up and now
was Kevin Lee and the reason why I love
Kevin Lee is because I think he's like
one of the best well-rounded fighters
out there and when I found out that the
Joe Rogan podcast was that he actually
didn't have a coach since his last coach
I think passed away and he was just
training himself for all of his matches
so he didn't have a game plan going into
the stuff aside from the stuff that he
was doing himself and he was doing
pretty decent now I was like how come he
can't really put these things together
so recently he's training with frost a
hobby ah
he fights uh Gillespie who by the way
hasn't lost at that point I think he was
undefeated at that point I haven't
really followed him that much but
everybody was hyping it up where it was
like yo Kevin he's gonna lose Kevin the
[ __ ] knocks him out with a head kick
which is amazing and people were shocked
because the people had Kevin Lee losing
that fight but that's just house how
that small little tweak and somebody's
game him getting a coach like for us to
really switch up his game and kind of
set up a game plan for him and how much
he changed him as a fighter which is
crazy because he was losing before and
then office and he has a head coach and
his whole game flips up but everybody
was down he look to that point that's
why I really believe like fighting is
seriously a small game of inches it's
like who was in your corner who's
training you know who can really like
set you up to be a great fighter yeah
that is so key coaches oh they are so
key not only is that but it's not just
the coaches that's in there teaching you
day in and day out but it's also the
coaches that's there on-site knowing how
to coach you during the fight because if
they can't speak and say things properly
it's you're gonna lose the fight no
matter how well-trained you are because
it's being coached when you're training
the skill versus also being coached a
day of the fight yeah so that's key
everything around you your team around
you your mentality and everything the
small
little things can make such a huge
difference so yeah I definitely believe
in that and yeah that's key to
everything
yeah when I think us one of the things
that I had trouble with when I was first
starting to do excited I did a tech one
when I was a kid and then they
kickboxing when I was twenty and then
what I'm starting to see now especially
what I like in coaches is a coach that
kind of finds what your style is versus
them imposing their style on you right
so they they keep saying things like
this is wrong this is better this is
better but instead of like looking at
what the fighters great at and kind of
developing that out of them I think that
kind of sometimes messes people up a lot
and for other fighters too if people do
start like competing and training I
think one of the the fun parts of
fighting is you finding your own style
yes like how do I like to fight am i am
i somebody who's a little bit more
defensive am i somebody who likes to
control the ring am i somebody who's it
depends on your style were you a karate
base are you in in an out fighter are
you somebody who just like to sit there
and bang it out like it really depends
on who you are and how you fight right
and like that's like the fun part it's
like well what's my style like you know
that is yeah I mean that's that's the
thing though when people I think that
goes for anything if if you're not a
good teacher or coach you're gonna end
up imposing what you think you know but
the thing is especially with martial
arts where every body type is different
you got to take that into consideration
it's like I think about jiu-jitsu were
some move that I'm taught it works so
well for someone but it doesn't work
well for me and vice versa it's like you
got this long dude with long limbs like
doing this one move versus my short ass
trying to do that move it's not gonna be
the same so you really have to look at
the body because even just someone being
long or short or thick or thin that's
gonna affect everything mmm
so after your MMA stuff you got picked
up to do WWE because people saw you so
what happened was um when I was training
MMA I got invited to go out to the
tapout ranch in Albuquerque's and then I
trained for about two weeks a little
mini fight camp out
at Greg Jackson's so I went out there
and I met this girl that write wrote for
fight magazine and she interview this
fighter that was on one of see who
fought Brandon Vera and so he added me
on Facebook because we have so many
mutual friends and the thing with
Albuquerque it's like really weird
because so tight-knit and small that if
one person adds you on as a friend on
Facebook the whole city adds you know
it's like the whole city everyone's just
adding me I'm just like what the [ __ ]
so this guy added me because of all our
friends and then he didn't say [ __ ] to
me for like four years
never said anything to me and I was like
okay I didn't think anything of it out
of nowhere after that when I had already
moved out here to California and it was
training out blockhouse he ends up
hitting me up and he goes hey I've been
watching you train I think you'd be
really good for WWE if you want to try
out let me know cuz he happened to be
friends with the old recruiter that was
there that guy's gone now but he was
friends with him and so he just because
he saw me training he was like oh she'd
be good and there you go like BAM I end
up getting an opportunity to try out but
my ass didn't know anything about WWE I
thought there was no way I get a chance
so this is my chance I'm like oh hell
yeah like my little childhood dream that
I thought was never possible is actually
coming in life I didn't know how to
train for it I was like I guess I'm be
training for it like I would for a fight
but without the striking so I was
training wrestling just pure wrestling
and also strengthen conditioning and
then my strength and conditioning coach
one day was like oh yeah if I come up I
might actually know I got tryout he's
like for what I said WWE he goes oh you
know there's a pro wrestling gym down
the street right and I was like what
there's pro wrestling gyms like that's a
real thing because I thought that you
have to know real like shoot wrestling
and then next thing you know you get
hired WWE and then they teach you their
stuff I didn't know there was actually
pro wrestling school it's a performance
art yeah I didn't know that like I
didn't know
I actually didn't even know it was a
performance art I thought it was amateur
wrestling yeah so [ __ ] funny I know
you're [ __ ] hilarious I thought it
was the same thing like I was just like
oh I just thought it was in my mind it's
the what left off but as what I saw as a
kid so kind of going to this gym turns
out to be Brian Kendrick school Santino
Brothers oh wow yeah so that's why I
trained out for two and a half no two
months two months and I just learned the
basics and got through to tryout and
next thing you know like in WWE I know
first of all what are your parents think
about your career choices it's saying
it's like you know yeah I don't know if
my parents would have been like oh yeah
you know that that thing that used to
[ __ ] break all of our furniture that
[ __ ] that used to watch [ __ ] up our
house that's what I want you to do for a
living cuz I used to [ __ ] [ __ ] up in my
house because of WWE [ __ ] things up so I
had a cousin he loved WWE with me and so
he used to watch this [ __ ] every [ __ ]
Thursday Thursday Night Smackdown and
because I was the one that came out on
public television I used to watch the
[ __ ] all the time and if my friends had
their [ __ ] on cable I would watch you
know what you know whatever [ __ ] was
it called like WCW or the other [ __ ] but
I used to love [ __ ] the rock so that
the rock [ __ ] the rock bottom was my
and we would pretend like the walls were
the [ __ ] that would you call it the
ropes and [ __ ] each other off I would
rock bottom this [ __ ]
bounce off dude the [ __ ] people's
elbow hit him with that [ __ ] one time
there's a couple of times I've really
[ __ ] up there was one time I was
trying to powerbomb this fool into the
couch so had him under my legs I flipped
them up and then I was gonna powerbomb
him but I kind of stepped backwards
because you know when you have somebody
at a power bond they're basically
sitting on your their dick is in your
face and they're sitting on you like a
chair and he tea-bagged you I missed the
[ __ ] couch and I slammed straight
onto the hardwood floor
I felt so [ __ ] bad all you heard it
was him go
with all the air [ __ ] went out and
then this other time I hurt angle
slammed him into into my bed but then I
did it too hard so I bent my [ __ ] bed
frame
my parents got so mad they beat my
[ __ ] ass and it made me sleep on that
on that curved bed for like two three
months like I used to [ __ ] people up
with that [ __ ] I love that [ __ ] like
hillbilly trash [ __ ] dude
hillbilly stuff lies in legend one there
was like people who would you know have
like their own WWE wrestling [ __ ] in
there back in their backyard and they
would [ __ ] each other up and then at
church we would have these folding
chairs that we was set up and I guess
what I did after church when we had to
fold it up I was smash that [ __ ] behind
people head I love that [ __ ] dude oh my
gosh like how did like wait how did you
get into that it was like that I think
it was just a my during my time when I
was like in the seventh or eighth grade
everybody was into that [ __ ] and even
before that it was like you know Hulk
Hogan basil oh my you I'm 32 oh what a
same age yes I'm 36 I used to love that
[ __ ] when I was a kid so it was it was
like the hottest thing out there
oh yeah cuz by then I had kind of
started falling out watching it so
that's why I wasn't you weren't into
that [ __ ] at that yeah because when you
probably see were the same age when you
were 12 or 13 which when you stop watch
yeah exactly like the hottest so 38 13
14 was when it was like the dopest [ __ ]
ever that's when I started yeah cuz
that's why I stopped watching it did you
did you ever get like seriously injured
while you're doing like the WWE yeah oh
god no I know a couple of dudes who got
really [ __ ] up there's a guy who
trained out in Vegas and he was he's
actually a guy that I met through like
the Caesars Palace and he works for them
I think his name I think he told me his
moniker was like the Phoenix dope is due
to ever [ __ ] nicest guy ever I love
this guy but he actually was his whole
life he wanted to be a pro wrestling he
was going through the whole training cap
and everything and he was doing like
amateur amateur you know WWE style
wrestling under his moniker like the
Phoenix he caught his spine compressed
oh and I think I forgot what the [ __ ]
but he [ __ ] up his backward he was
lifting somebody up or some [ __ ] and he
did it improperly and his spine just
compacted pop pop pop pop pop oh God so
he was [ __ ] up because I know a lot of
people who get hurt during that [ __ ]
yeah I mean yeah I would I would say I
mean I dislocated my shoulder
it took my same one yeah same one [ __ ]
yeah it twice so I dislocated it when I
got thrown landed on it wrong and then I
got the second time and dislocated again
was when I got like thrown and it just
so we were outside of the Ring we're
fighting outside of ring and then I got
thrown to the metal part underneath yeah
so then it I hit it so hard it came out
again so I [ __ ] up the shoulder and it
put me out for a while and then I think
from this being [ __ ] up I don't know
what caused it but something happened
where it just gave me some type of thing
in my back on the same side where it was
bothering me for like a year and a half
yeah a year and a half it just it was so
tight and it affected my whole neck it
would be something as simple as me
turning my head and I will pull my whole
neck like constantly damn it hasn't
happened recently so I'm assuming it
like healed but I think that's probably
the worst injury and uh probably be you
know uh probably concussion a little bit
you know but concussions well what
happened to your [ __ ] knees then your
knees are all [ __ ] Zephyr that's from
MMA god damn it yeah this popped out
during MMA because I was no more Thai
and I pivoted to turn my toe got caught
in between the mat so my foot was stuck
there and then my whole body turn
[ __ ] hate when I get freaked out when
that happens if you have really shitty
mats that's what it was shitty puzzle
mats back yeah so like though people
still have those [ __ ] [ __ ] ass puzzle
mats man yeah and my toe so there's I
used to trade this place to Sacramento
and they had those you know the red and
blue [ __ ] puzzle mats and then when
you would rotate or pivot or you would
even try to move laterally some of those
puzzle ships comes apart yeah
then your [ __ ] toe gets stuck in that
[ __ ] huh that's the way you hurt
yourself huh yep in my whole knee like
blew out on us it was like popping it
was falling and falling in and out like
so easily it was so loose and falling in
and out every day for a year and a half
Wow and never got surgery on it and I
met this Olympic wrestling coach that
taught me this PT workout I went crazy
went ham on it for like an hour straight
with no rest every single day for almost
a month straight and healed it never had
an issue since Wow yeah so I basically
healed his knee even though it was a
third-degree tear I told my ACL fully my
LCL is probably fully tear torn I'm
about to get an MRI to get it checked
out because I've never actually seen it
since it tore back in 2008 so and I
almost didn't get hired by WWE because
of it because they saw it and they're
like you have a fully torn ACL we can't
hire you because that's the thing if you
don't have no ACL torn ACL you are not
hired yeah but because I trained it so
hard that I was able to keep it in and I
was able to do everything and I remember
I was so pissed so this is what happened
I was at the time so I'm friends with Jo
Stephenson from UFC he used to be the
fight choreographer for that Nick Jonas
TV show the kingdom yeah so he asked me
to be on the show and he was actually
trying to get me to he told me I was
gonna be on a season four you know it
wasn't be like a 3-4 months of filming
and at this time I had already gone to
we4 tryout and then I got signed they
door they told me I was hired sign my
contract sent it in two days later and
oh yeah so sent it in two days later I'm
on set because uh they told so I wasn't
actually supposed to start officially
until July 2017 but it made me come half
a year early in January 2017 and which
kind of ruined my chance
for the TV show and so when I told them
I was like hey can I come in July
because I got this TV show I want to do
and they were like no it's either us or
them so I picked WWE and I didn't take
it and instead I just did background
work and when I was there on set Jo
announced to everyone on set and told
him you know yeah my friend got signed
to WWE and so everyone's here
congratulating me and then that day I'm
driving home I'm driving driving through
Hollywood and next thing you know the
main dude from WWE calls me and he goes
hey are you sitting down right now and I
was like I'm driving what's up he goes
unis a park and sit down I was like okay
so I parked and he goes yeah we can't
hire you you have no ACL you're
high-risk and I was like what I was like
I had I was already gonna move out that
week I already I quit all my jobs quit
all my jobs and signed everything like I
was ready to move out that week yeah and
then he tells me I'm not hired after
they announce to everyone that I'm
Valdez Levenstein I'm just like what the
[ __ ] I was like what do you mean like
you saw me through my whole tryout I can
obviously do everything I had my whole
MMA career on it like I'm fine my knee
works fine and he's like nope you're
high-risk can't hire you sorry hung up
on me
I was in shock and I was like so in
shock and literally as soon as we hung
up on the phone this woman's getting
robbed and this guy like steals our
parts and starts running and at the
second I was already pissed and I was
just like [ __ ] this [ __ ] and I would
chase II after the dealer saw I saw why
did you have a [ __ ] saw because my
dad told me uh he said because I used to
okay so when I first moved out of
California I was homeless for almost
half a year hey oh yeah I was sleeping
out my car and I had a sword because I
used to have a sword collection I still
have it a sword collection and I kept a
katana in my car some pocket knives and
in case someone tried to like a
me because I almost got abducted when I
was out here - I was got abducted for
real when I came to California already
like some guys try to get me in his van
oh my god keep on trying to lead you
like these dark alleyways and [ __ ] no
what does it about you that people keep
trying to rape you my god it haven't so
much I had to pull my knife out on
someone twice like twice one in Virginia
and one when I moved out here
what part of where were you at I was on
La Brea Oh what the [ __ ] yeah I was on a
highway of La Brea and there was seven
o'clock in the summer so the Sun was
still out yeah my car was [ __ ] and it
broke down on me and started like
heating and stuff the smoke was coming
out so I literally just got out popped
the trunk not even ten seconds later I
turn around there's two dudes behind me
and one guy was like oh your car's just
overheating let it cool off pour some
water in and you're good to go and I was
I had just moved here to California I
was like oh everyone here so nice you
know everyone in Cali is so nice helping
me out and then the dude told the other
do you good and that dudes like yeah so
I first I thought they came together but
then the other guy stayed behind and I
was like okay and that guy was like
talking to me but he had like really
poor English so he was just kind of like
saying something about cars and then he
was like blah blah blah you want to get
my van and I was like no thanks that's
ok and then all of a sudden we'll be
talking about something else and then
he'll say it again you want to get my
van and I was like no thank you and he
goes yeah you can get in my van and
stuff I'm like no no that's cool I gotta
head to work and stuff I I'm gonna wait
till my car it cools down you're good
but thank you though I really appreciate
it and then he'll he'll continue talking
as if we weren't even on the subject he
will just start talking about cars
something about cars and then he said it
again you don't get my van and I was
like no and I started getting annoyed at
this point it was like four or five
times he's asking me I'm like no why am
I getting your van like I don't need to
get in your van and then he goes oh you
know it's dangerous out here we're on
the side of the road and I'm like no no
it's not I got my hazard lights on on
the side of the road we're not in
traffic we're fine
and then all of sudden he gets in my
face like this close and he goes get in
my van [ __ ] yelled at me to get in his
van and at this point you know I've
already dealt with all the [ __ ] in
Virginia I've gotten almost raped so
many times and almost normal walk in the
park is like you just told me you know
how many times people have tried to get
me in their van it's never happened just
move on at this point I was like he's
got mad he just snapped huh yeah he
snapped and I got mad I was like the
first thing I thought was I can't please
dude [ __ ] yelled at me yeah and I
[ __ ] there's a summer time and I was
still broke I left my I roll my windows
down cuz I couldn't afford to use AC so
good [ __ ] went around and when in my
car got my phone to call the cops got
the knife in my other hand I'm dialing
911 next thing you know because the
windows are down he reaches his hand in
and bends my arm back to knock he bends
it back and he didn't see I had a knife
in this hand I'm like get the [ __ ] off
me don't [ __ ] touch me and he goes
woah I'm sorry you can trust me I'm just
trying to help you I'm like no [ __ ] off
for me that's a Tweaker dude yep I bet
he was on drugs and he was trying to
abduct my ass and get him in his [ __ ]
like one of those rapist vans it was
legit like a movie the white sliding
door with no window van those Walker
vans that's what he was trying to give
me in what the [ __ ] yeah and then he
turned back around I like had my knife
over here and I I remember thinking to
myself I'm in California am I allowed to
stab him there's all these people
driving like if I stab him I'm gonna get
in trouble I don't know laws out here
and I'm just like thinking all these
things and then I told my parents about
what happened and my dad's like yeah
just get a saw because you can't get in
trouble cuz it's a tool that's why you
saw in your [ __ ] car
your dad's hilarious you're not
completely ignore the fact that you
almost got raped because hey hey hey why
don't you get a saw next time be a
little more careful you can open it and
not use a [ __ ] saw oh my god he's
like not even hearing about the part
where the guy was raped you yeah [ __ ]
and no they actually I think they're so
you said this point do they know you
were homeless no because of course you
would
tell them I knew you'd yeah I don't tell
them yeah cuz like you just kidding here
with no [ __ ] money they use no okay
it's a long story so the there's a lot
of things that went into it yeah I moved
away from Virginia because of several
things um I was doing MMA out there and
I ended up dating this guy that was the
allstar of the gym and he was like a UFC
prospect that's time and well what's
[ __ ] up is he was abusive where he was
abused physically he said I was an
abusive relationship and I was stuck
with him I was took on lease with him so
financially I was [ __ ] politically I
was [ __ ] because my coach told him
told me not to give him locked up in
jail because he was like the next guy
yeah what's his name say his [ __ ]
name did he even get to you see nope he
end up turning into a stripper thai
stripper this was just [ __ ] Jitsu on
dicks now huh look at that pretty much
this guy named Mike Wade Mike Wade you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you probably kill if you
met me a person but you don't live in
California do you little [ __ ] and yeah
yeah [ __ ] you Mike wait wait on deez
nutz [ __ ] Oh God he's probably still
really buff cuz he's a stripper he's a
[ __ ] stripper he's doing steroids
he's selling coke I don't know what the
[ __ ] else he's doing but he's not
winning at life at all yeah so yeah he
was [ __ ] abusive and um I try to
[ __ ] leave and there was just so many
ways I was [ __ ] financially I was
stuck with him on a lease and the thing
is the lease wouldn't let me out
I was co-signed with him because his
credit sucked and I had awesome 800
credit score [ __ ] so they took the
average of 600 and that's how we even
got the apartment so we lived together
and he he ended up having a [ __ ] DUI
so I had to drive him around and [ __ ]
and then we're stuck on this damn lease
and he wouldn't sign me
the only way I get out of the lease is
be signed out or I would have to pay a
$3,500 termination fee which I didn't
have and my parents didn't know I was
living together with someone because my
parents were traditional and they're
like you can't of course live with
anyone until you're married type of
thing so they didn't know any of this
and I had to keep a secret and the next
thing you know I can't get him locked up
because of my gym and my career if I get
him locked up and [ __ ] up my coach that
[ __ ] up my career in turn of that and
on top of that I couldn't get out lease
unless I had a police report but I'm not
allowed to lock him in up in jail
because I'd be [ __ ] politically and my
career wise so I was just [ __ ] all the
way around and I was just trying to
think of a way out and I couldn't and at
first you know it was crazy like he was
everything went so well for the first
eight months eight months that's a long
time to upkeep a fake facade yeah that
[ __ ] comes out pretty quick quick nah
that's dude I'm pretty sure he was a
[ __ ] sociopath cuz I talked to people
about this because everyone it was so
many things everyone we had so many
mutual friends just because the MMA
circuit you know we I knew this dude
from like a long time ago and I always
avoided dating him because I'm honest I
didn't want date him he just [ __ ]
claimed me which I was pissed but it was
whatever so I already knew him three
years before we started like dating and
I always avoided him because I don't
want to date within my industry and so
next thing you know he is talking to me
and stuff and when we were talking he
was telling me how he was getting his
second master's degree and [ __ ] like
that I was like oh okay so he has a
brain he's not some douchebag meathead
and stuff like that and so okay he seems
not too bad so I was like cool with him
then one day he came up to Richmond and
I was like oh yeah I'm in town and stuff
do you want to hang out with me and my
cousin and we didn't we hung out and
stuff and then next thing you know we
hooked up and I even though it was
like I felt kind of forced at the time
but it didn't end up being like pretty
good so I was like alright well at least
the sex was kind of good so okay cool
so we just kept kind of hooking up for a
little bit and I kind of want to keep a
secret I wanted to keep a secret I don't
want anyone know about it because I
didn't want to get involved with anyone
with an MMA and even though he wasn't in
my gym he was under the same franchise
or the gym I was at even though he lived
like three and a half hours away next
thing you know he ends up moving up to
my gym he moves up to my gym and he was
at a party with my teammates and on the
phone he just [ __ ] claimed me and
told everyone that I was his girlfriend
and I was just like whoa what the [ __ ]
like we're supposed to keep this [ __ ] a
secret yeah and now everyone knows well
alright cool i guess and everything was
going well at the time so I thought it
was cool and everyone liked him he was a
good liar everyone liked him thought he
was a good person
and I thought he was a good person all
the way until six months after we move
in together
we're in together two months in and then
one day we get a [ __ ] argument over
something so dumb I honestly we got in
arguments over so many things I can't
remember but I think it was one of the
times where he got angry at me because
my hair was on the floor you know how
people shed their [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah he got
mad because naturally my hair shed in
the bathroom floor and he started
yelling at me about that I was like what
the [ __ ] and so and we got an argument
and next thing you know he picked me up
my neck and threw me
yeah and strangled me and that was the
first time I was like in shock I I was
like I'm in an abusive relationship and
I didn't know how to get out yeah and
during this time I was like and the
crazy thing is I was I was doing well my
career at the time I was doing well in
MMA and at this time I was arguing a fan
base and woman would tell me and say
they look up to me and how strong of a
woman I am and Here I am getting abused
and it just wasn't a good look
all the way around you feel like a fraud
yeah it made me feel like I couldn't
talk to anyone I had to keep up that
front cuz it's like well these people
look up to me and then if you kind of
you kind of put into this weird
situation you feel like you don't have
anybody to talk to because you're
supposed to be everybody's role model
exactly no and no one knew about I
couldn't tell my friends I couldn't tell
anyone and the few people I did tell
that I was friends with that Jim liked
like I don't know if they believe me
only one guy believed me but also the
politics of it was he was the biggest
dude this dude was like 215 pounds of
muscle
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's a big boy he's a big
boy yeah like he even though he could
cut down and fight to 170 but he walked
around to 15 so I was 121 at the time
I'm tiny and he's a pro fighter like
what the [ __ ] am I gonna do to him like
there's nothing I could do and so and
all the people even the ones who did
believe me at the gym wouldn't stand up
for me because they were too scared that
he would beat him up beat them up
because he does he kind of just bullies
everyone at the gym and stuff so they
were too scared to piss him off and
everyone's on his [ __ ] dick because
like he's supposed to be a next UFC
prospect and [ __ ] so everyone's just
like all like oh my god Mike you know
like it's some [ __ ] so because of
that like people and it [ __ ] like it
hurt me because I was at this gym for
like five and a half years I was there
way before he was there and then so
quickly I see people's true colors and
they jump ship and take his side and say
that I'm the crazy one now I'm know like
I'm done [ __ ] like I'm so quiet and shy
they think that I'm the [ __ ] crazy
when I started but that's because he was
so good at putting up this front that he
was such a good guy so no one believed
me and the ones who did they wouldn't
stick up for me so I felt stuck in this
situation and at the time you know I I
did love him at the time and I I guess I
had abused woman syndrome a little bit
when I was there and I guess I didn't
realize
the severity of the matter and I'll and
it got to a point where one night we're
laying on the couch watching Netflix
watching this one documentary called
like who the [ __ ] did I marry on mystery
ID and one episode was about a husband
and wife and the husband was abusive and
a wife tried to leave him and he shot
her in the back of the head and killed
her
and he turned around and said to me
that's what i'ma do to you if you ever
try to leave me and I took it as a joke
I'm like ah funny like I think it's
serious but then a few months later like
a few months had passed few months later
were watching another episode and again
he goes that's Holman duty if you ever
leave me oh my god no I was just like
yeah and the thing is and he said to me
and past before that uh
if I ever get him locked up his dad
would come and kill me and his dad was
locked up for ten years for assault and
uh I started getting a little worried I
was like okay this is months has passed
obviously you've been thinking about the
[ __ ] and then he said it again so then
the third time he said it he had bought
a gun he bought a gun and kept it loaded
in front of us in front of it the living
room table where we laid and I thought
to myself oh my god this guy's gonna
kill me for real yeah and I started he
said it again the third time and I got
like kind of yeah worried and I was like
what the hell like are you like why do
you keep saying this at this point like
eight and a half months had passed and I
was like why do you keep saying this
it's been eight and a half months
there's a third time you said it to me
like like are you are you trying to kill
me or something and he's like oh no I
love you I would never do that blah blah
blah and then I thought to myself
dude he's legit gonna kill me in it and
I had to figure out a way to get out of
the situation so instead I told him I
was gonna move all my summer stuff or my
winter stuff to my parents place and
move all my summer stuff in and I was
gonna switch stuff out but really I was
packing all my important stuff and he
was helping me move the boxes into my
car I had the doors open on both sides
and I had this giant ass box I can't see
where I'm going
next thing you know he's yelling at me
he's like open the [ __ ] doors and I'm
like the doors are open and he's like
open the [ __ ] doors I'm gonna throw
all your [ __ ] on the floor and at the
time I was doing graphic design that was
like kind of my job and I had my
computer in there that's my work I was
like no my computer is another don't
throw on the ground if you're if you're
it's too heavy and can't hold it put on
top of card put it on the ground next
thing you know he goes I'm in the middle
of putting the [ __ ] in my car and as I'm
putting in
I hear him and go nope and that by time
I turn around he Chuck's all my [ __ ]
he's like 6 1 he he's like holding on up
here Chuck's it up and drops all my [ __ ]
on the ground and I'm my computer's
[ __ ] in there recycle he's [ __ ]
psycho and I was [ __ ] yes yeah and
I'm like what the [ __ ] I just [ __ ]
told you in any time I even say anything
back he gets physical he gets in my face
and he goes shut the [ __ ] up or I will
shoot you in the [ __ ] face and when
we go to court I will just tell the
judge that I thought you were intruder
and that's why I shot ya he sent all
that [ __ ] and I'm just like thinking to
myself oh my god how long did he think
about all that like how how do you think
of that and then all that [ __ ] like
obviously even think about that [ __ ] and
so I told my like I'm leaving and I put
the car in my ignition he breaks the key
out of my ignition cuts my hand open
because he was pulling it out of my hand
and luckily at the time there was a
police officer patrolling that area
he was can I help you is there a problem
here and I was a guy he won't let me
leave and [ __ ] left never turned back
went all the way back home to
Charlottesville Virginia where my
parents were and I was working on my
parents place for three and a half
months saving up money to come out to
California yeah and then from that
people got word that I was moving out
here and he heard that I was moving out
here and so he tried to keep some pull
some [ __ ] to keep me from leaving
because he kept apologizing after and
trying to get back together with me but
I kept telling him no and then two weeks
before I was gonna come out here he
pulls some [ __ ] and went
to the cops and told them that I was the
one who attacked him and trying to get
me locked up in jail and I was like what
the [ __ ] and so I went and spent all the
money I had saved up on the lawyer I
went to the police place to buy all the
call logs if all the times I called the
cops on him and had the cops come and
escort me out and I had to do that
because I wasn't gonna take a chance on
getting locked up and the reason why
that was is because one of the times
that he picked me up by my neck and
strangled me he held me down and choked
me until I almost passed out I remember
right before I was about to black out I
thought to myself oh my god I'm gonna
die tonight if I don't do anything and
instinctually I grabbed his face and I
pushed it and my nail cut the side of
his nose and it was bleeding I called
the cops on him to get them in and the
stupid-ass cop they're supposed to
separate you guys and ask you questions
separately but the bitch-ass dumbass cop
he asked me do you want to press charges
right in front of him he's standing
right there and he's standing behind the
cop and he goes well do you like
mouthing the words well do you you want
to press charges on me huh you want to
press charges and at the moment I was
thinking [ __ ] everything [ __ ] my career
like [ __ ] this I'm gonna press charges
imma get him locked up and [ __ ]
everything but then when I saw him I got
intimidated and I told him no I was like
no and then though a female cop took him
outside and asked him questions
separately of course he [ __ ] lied and
said I attacked him and then she came in
and she gave me an attitude and she goes
he told me that you he uh you were the
one that attacked him I was like what
the [ __ ] oh I just say what the [ __ ] I
was like what no I did not like I'm the
one who called you guys I'm like he
strangled me and I pushed his face away
and that's why I cut him and I'm like
it's like you're not gonna see bruises
when you get strangled it shows up hours
later yeah and so she told me I was like
what the hell I'm like that's not what
happened and then she told me to shut up
or all she's gonna take me to jail Wow
I was like are you [ __ ] serious like
are you [ __ ] serious
like I can't believe I'm getting the
tables turn on me yeah because of his
lies and I wasn't gonna ruin my whole
life in future because of this
[ __ ] so I went in and and I knew
at this time already when the abuse
started happening I knew that our
relationship was gonna end in court yeah
so one of the times that another time he
[ __ ] he took a belt in with me
for 30 minutes straight and I secretly
recorded it on my phone
oh Sh I was gonna I was gonna say like
did you ever record any of these
interactions because like this is
because this happened so repetitively
it's like well now you gotta you gotta
[ __ ] read up on this [ __ ] you know
yeah I uh I recorded the whole thing
when he was like whipping me and [ __ ]
and calling me a [ __ ] dog and and
when I went to court I play that in
court and what sucked was uh I had to
play it and from my dad I heard like
everything so um like sorry no it's okay
um so it was like really hard cuz my
parents like I had to keep that [ __ ]
secret and uh then it was like my dad
had to really hear about all the [ __ ]
and uh so after that I put a restraining
order on him and all the money that I
had saved up to go to California I had
like $3,200 at the time it all went to
court fees and lawyers and everything
and um after that I came out to
California with $800 [ __ ] yeah and when
I came out I had no job no friends like
I didn't know anyone like nothing I have
no one out here so I just came out here
and my parents thought everything was
fine and but really I came out with a
[ __ ] car my mom had this BMW and the
thing was the BMW was a 2001 and you
know BMW have all these electrical
problems I'll show you so it's like the
car it looked nice cuz she kept it nice
it's a silver ass BMW and so I'm getting
harassed everywhere my car is breaking
down in every [ __ ] time I braked
happens to be in Compton or Inglewood
like it's in some [ __ ] place and I'm
so sure like people are bothering me and
stuff and like $400 here $400 here you
know money just went away so quick next
thing you know I had nothing I was
sleeping out in the car and I just had
to work random jobs to try and make
money cuz it was so hard to get a
[ __ ] job out here and because I was
just working on random bars and I was
modeling here and there I used to like
import modeling and whatever so sell
some merchandise here and there and make
some random money here and there and
that would keep me going until you know
I was kind of up on my feet until
finally I you know I worked over for a
while and then I worked at this music
studio and start getting more money and
then when I started getting more money I
ended up investing all my money in my
training so I still stayed in my car
because I was it was enough to be able
to do both you know actually no at the
time I was investing oh I forgot I also
got scammed I think I [ __ ] over dude
yeah like I came out here and I was I
decided to quit MMA because I I didn't
want to run into him because you know
I'm a circle small yeah I don't want to
run into him and I was so angry with the
MMA community because I'm like everyone
like turn my back on me to take sides
with this [ __ ] like I don't want
to deal with this community anymore and
I [ __ ] wanna just pursue music cuz
honestly that was my first love was
pursuing music and so I came out here
for some music and then I think I got
[ __ ] over by this fake-ass producer
that was taking tons of money from me so
all my money that I made I gave it to
him gave to him to a point where I just
couldn't anymore and then one of my
friends Cub Swanson he was talking to me
Oh jamika when I went out to Albuquerque
at Greg Jackson's oh yeah yeah yeah so
he's always been really cool with me and
he just gave me advice like you know I
should get back into them MA and so
because of him saying that I decided to
go back and train and so I that's
joined a black house and started you
know spending all my money in there and
I was sleeping on my car until it got to
a point where I got enough money to be
able to have a place to stay and go
train and then next thing you know I end
up
signed in a VW after that but that's
[ __ ] crazy
I mean to experience with like it's
weird because you know I think our
parents always want us to like reach out
and ask for their help but then like the
problem is is like it's not really a
problem is more of our individual issues
that we have because we just don't want
them to see our failures right because
they kind of invest so much into you and
they kind of we almost have to lie to
them because we don't want them to see
all of our imperfections right and that
makes you feel like you're just
disappointed you know just because like
I mean you know I wasn't born here I was
born in Korea so I'm an immigrant so I'm
I'm generation 0 right so or first first
gen or whatever and so when I I mean I
don't do it now but I could see why a
lot of people do it where it's just like
[ __ ] how hard is it for me to say like I
failed like I you invested all this time
into me and I [ __ ] failed and you
know when you're in court and you see
your father just having to go through
that and see his daughter you know I
asked what by this guy it's like I'll
[ __ ] like I must been really frightening
for you yeah and it sucks because like
the thing is it's not like I didn't know
about like I didn't know when it
happened but the thing is I grew up
around ant that's been abused and my
parents used to say don't ever end up
like your aunt if a guy hits you what
you gonna do I'm like I would [ __ ]
hit his ass back all right [ __ ] leave
him but the problem was he was a [ __ ]
I couldn't his ass back should I
couldn't would have dated a [ __ ]
computer tech geek yeah that hates
violence and has never trained a day in
his life
yeah that's that's what I go for now cuz
book that [ __ ] you know like um so it
was that and also I'm the only child
yeah and my parents bake they grew up
poor they came to us with nothing um
worked their asses off and my dad dude
he is like he is the oldest guy out of
four kids well he had two older brothers
that died but so technically he was the
oldest and yeah
three younger sisters had to take care
of and in the Chinese culture if you're
a male it's like your job to take care
of the whole family so he came to us
with nothing and worked his ass off and
took care of his whole family as mom is
that his three sisters and then he
brought them to the US and took care of
them and then one of his sisters try to
[ __ ] him over and steal his money and
steal our restaurant and steal our condo
and all this [ __ ] [ __ ] and so also my
dad was married to a woman before and
like this woman was a gold-digging ass
[ __ ] that spent all his money and then
her daughter was the same way and she
always takes advantage of my dad our dad
or whatever and my dad's just like too
nice of a person and he keeps like I
feel so bad because he's done so much
nice stuff for people and people just
[ __ ] him over and I felt like it was my
job to you know give back to my parents
because they've done so much for me they
worked so hard to try to put me in the
best schools and they try to put me in
private schools and [ __ ] like that and
even though they couldn't afford and I
was the poorest person there and I
couldn't go to private school
consistently because they wouldn't have
enough money every year to send me there
it's like if they had money that year I
went to private school if I didn't
couldn't go to private school so I
switched around schools a lot and it
just they of course wanted me to be a
lawyer a doctor but to be honest I was
never good at academics and I started
English so late I didn't even understand
what the [ __ ] I was learning in school
so it really put me behind and it
affected my academics I'm not like
consider smart and their standards and
the only thing I was really good at was
art and art you know it's frowned upon
there's a real starving artist and my
parents just didn't want me to do that
and had to convince them my whole life
that I was good at it to let me go to
art school so finally I went to art
school in Richmond Virginia at VCU
because they're known for their art
program and I went for a graphic design
but unfortunately when I started doing
graphic design when I was 14 it was
still the new thing no one was doing it
by the time I got to college age this
market was oversaturated
and no one's making money off of it and
so I'm here like doing all this and I
just felt like I was a disappointment
and during I went to school I felt like
I was doing it for them I wasn't doing
it for me I did it to please them I want
to graduate for them but secretly I was
training secretly I was doing music
secretly I was Mali and doing anything
art-related acting and all that so then
to just go and not be a lawyer a doctor
and after they spent all that money on
my education just to turn around and ask
for money I just couldn't do that yeah I
didn't want to take anything from them
because I retook so much so of course I
didn't I never asked for anything from
them and I never like to ask for money
or let them know that I was in need of
anything so just never told them so like
when you were out here so it was like
you're struggling just couldn't I just
didn't say anything I don't think I'd be
able to ask them for money like that
either I think like I have asked my
parents for money before and that was
before I was doing well you know it was
hard
no she was rough you know asking them
for money it was like look like it kind
of it kind of [ __ ] you up cuz I you
know I worked in my parents business too
so I know how hard they work and I know
what it takes to earn that little amount
of money that they would get and there
for me to take away from that [ __ ]
because I wasn't adequate enough to make
my own living yes we made me feel like
[ __ ] yeah I completely understand how
that feels man I mean it's I think a lot
of like Asian kids kind of go through
that [ __ ] - yeah it's it's it's a good
thing because we we have this thing
where number one we could empathize with
our parents and their struggles and then
it also makes us try to work harder
because we don't want to just take away
from our parents because at a certain
point - like we want to be able to give
back that's that's that's like the the
part that I always look forward to like
recently my dad he doesn't really ask
for much he doesn't ask for a lot right
I might ask [ __ ] annoying by the way
but I love him to death he had he's had
like a shitty laptop right and I'm phone
you know I've offered him to buy him a
laptop a few times here and there but
he's like I don't need it I don't need
it finally his two shitty [ __ ]
laptops finally bust which by the way
they're really crappy and so my mom asks
for
my mom asks for him he's like hey can
you buy your dad a laptop I was like
yeah of course and you know when I
bought it it was just it was it was like
whatever like I make the money so I
bought him a laptop and I sent it over
and he's super happy and then I kind of
thought about it like yeah it's kind of
cool that I'm in a position now where if
they need something I can get him
something that he wants right because
before I couldn't do that I absolutely I
absolutely couldn't if he needed
something I'd be like hey man you're
asked out like I need electricity food
my stuff around got that you know but
it's one of those like good feelings
that you have cuz you know about your
pair of struggle and you know I think in
your situation too like having your
parents warn you about all these things
about going into art and it kind of like
having to come to court and see him be
in a situation he warned you about it's
like but like I kind of it's like his
not so much as I told you so moment but
it's like [ __ ] like I kind of made his
worst nightmares come true exactly and
it's just like I didn't want to be
another burden you know and so I just
couldn't ask for a day I didn't tell
them anything and you still have a
restraining order on that guy
no it expired it only lasts like I think
it only I think I only last like three
years or some [ __ ] and you have to be up
on it or something are you up on it what
the [ __ ] is should last forever
yeah it should last forever but stupid
you know that's [ __ ] crazy
and his crazy ass contact me all the way
up until 2016 I broke up with his ass
end of 2012 damn that's not that long
ago
I know so he was like like text me he
was [ __ ]
he was dude I blocked him from
everything and he would make a new
account and hit me up he would find me
online saying like what was he trying to
do he was telling me how he he was sorry
and how much he loved me and how proud
he was of me proud [ __ ] everybody says
they're proud of you actually you become
something to use like don't even try and
say that [ __ ] yeah and just like China
you know trying to get back together
type of thing or try and be in my good
graces but I was like no [ __ ] I just
ignored it and I just keep blocking all
the accounts he keeps making he's making
every account I keep having to reblock
him keep blocking every account but I do
he was he's [ __ ] psycho that's crazy
well I mean after now that you're done
with the WWE and stuff and it's kind of
cool though I think like the the
greatest takeaway from this too and I
think like from every
that you set up into this point is that
your person you're a person of like
resilience there's like when something
pushes you here you push back ten times
harder which is why you've been able to
survive up into this point right and I
think like the hard part about kind of
doing entertainment or what we do is
said it's a very difficult [ __ ] route
like when you pop off you pop off well
but even then just because you popped
off once doesn't mean you're good for
the rest of your life it doesn't work
out that way that's that's the really
hard reality of entertainment and so
even when I go back home sometimes
people like you've made it I haven't
made [ __ ] like what are you talking
about like just because I got this one
gig and this one job it doesn't mean I
stopped working I have to continue to
work I don't have steady income yeah
like I got it she trying at this over
and over and over again you know when I
started off this podcast originally - it
was it was hard for people to see why I
switched my channel into a podcast and
what you know why I told people recently
like in in my when I started my patreon
was that people don't know like YouTube
doesn't make money anymore like I know
if so it's like there's a few people on
top that make a lot of money and those
are people who do children's channels
I'm not a children's channel like I
don't have children because because
they're very advertiser friendly so
that's the stuff that YouTube and Google
pushes up to the top that's the one they
put the most ad dollars in I'm not a
[ __ ] children's channel and I can't
be I can't stop cursing I can't change
who I am and it's who I was who I have
been and I and I couldn't do that so I
decide to switch to a podcast format and
kind of you know work through ad dollars
instead where I garner the ads myself
versus having waiting for the YouTube to
give me a [ __ ] ad and so people
couldn't see why I did that and then I
had to make that change and you know
that's the only reason why the channels
still going that's why we had this
podcast office you know but it was hard
for people to see him that's just like
that struggle of being an artist you
kind of had to figure out your own way
yes I mean YouTube worked for me for
about eight years and just like okay
cool and then what's the next step so I
had to kind of like look ahead and see
what I can do next it's so tough because
entertainment it changes with the
technology yeah so every time it changes
that affects you yeah Instagram take
talk now yeah take talk now it's just
like we're in a weird time right now
where all these things that we're
working before is dying and then tick
tock is so new that it's like pop it off
it's not enough
I'd like this Chinese company so it has
billions of millions of dollars like
back behind it so it would be good so
what are you doing now now that you're
done with the WWE so I just got signed
to another company major league
Wrestling and it's it's awesome because
a lot of like famous wrestlers has gone
there and a lot of WWE people are in
there and xww people are currently in
there and such they're back and forth
you know but I'm injured
okay I'm injured so as you know when we
were training yesterday my AC at my
other a sales fully torn and LCL and god
dammit yeah
so everything's torn but the goal right
now is to just rehab hard and get back
because the good thing about mlw is I've
worked for them before like they were
the first TV company that I worked for
after WWE and their good show and
everything has a good following and so
it's nice to be the first woman signed
on their company that's awesome yeah and
they're gonna push me and I'm the one
who start started woman's division they
didn't never had one before so I'm gonna
be you know building their woman's
division but then now I'm injured so now
it's just a matter of getting healthy
and getting back into it but meanwhile I
am still wrestling but I'm being picky
with who I choose cuz I got to stay
healthy yeah and right now you know just
merchandise sales luckily just all
merchandise sales and stuff and of
course I am also kind of doing stunts
here and there because I've always
enjoyed all forms of entertainment like
whether it's acting or music or any type
of entertainment art I'd be happy doing
all of it so it's just whatever comes
you know so doing that got my website up
and all that and basically also doing
some music going yeah doing some music
again but the thing is I do have vocal
nodules my voice is messed up from all
the screen
with wrestling and MMA but one of my
friends he was actually my photographer
but this guy that goes by icon he used
to be signed with Grand Hustle records
but he is a arm B singer but he ended up
getting screwed over by the industry so
he kind of has a bitter taste in his
mouth but now he is working with Kevin
McCall oh yeah Kevin McCall is his
friend yeah but you know Kevin McCall
there's a falling out in industry
because he had a falling out with Chris
Brown and all that that sucks too
because like Kevin McCall is like
talented well I mean I don't know if
people know but Kevin McCall did a bunch
of like Chris Brown's background
Braca of locals which they don't even
[ __ ] know like that's like Kevin
McCall voice and he wrote a lot of [ __ ]
so it's like all the stuff that you
loved about Chris Brown is because it
Kevin McCall but that's like stuff like
if you're really into music like you
wouldn't know that [ __ ] yeah so all that
[ __ ] that you hear when you know you
hear all these like dope ass harmonies
that's not [ __ ] Chris Brown and
that's Kevin McCall doing it he's doing
all the background vocals yeah yeah he's
a good writer great singer like
everything so he's trying to make a
comeback right now on me so you know
we're kind of working on this album and
it's more icons album yeah and so we're
kind of both on this album kind of
working on it so it's just a project I
don't know where it goes but it's just
funny how when I wanted the music
connection it wasn't there for me but
now that I'm in wrestling they seem to
be coming all over the place and I'm
working on my entrance song because I'm
back and forth between here in Asia a
tour yeah and so I wanted an entrance
song that was half chinese half English
so I wrote the song and the I was trying
to find a Mandarin rapper and next thing
you know this guy named Jason Chu hit me
up he wrote he has like two songs on the
whoa assassin and warrior one soundtrack
okay so we're collaborating together
he's gonna be the rapper on my song and
so that's my little project that I'm
doing so though that that and you know
wrestling is still main focus right now
okay what are you gonna start uh-huh
it's whenever you're done you rehab but
then you start wrestling or what's the
time span I'm gonna rehab hard as [ __ ]
and basically when I get
proved by a doctor I'm gonna wrestle but
I mean our half shows lined up I'm being
picky about it but I am going out to
China March again to wrestle out there
that's awesome snow it's gonna be fun
and I am doing autograph signings so I'm
doing autograph signing this Friday at
pcw ultra so doing that and then the
week after I'm doing a little show for
my gym because the gym I trained out of
for pro wrestling in oke dojo they're
doing a little show how show thing so
I'm doing it support you know they're
letting me train there and all that so
yeah so I'm basically doing all that and
but I'm being picky about what shows to
do I mean I'm definitely open to take
wrestling matches it just depends on who
I work with yes at the end day I have to
protect his knee cuz mlw is priority
yeah yeah yeah
okay well [ __ ] I don't know how long we
were going for do we were going for a
while almost two hours I know damn 40
minutes [ __ ] well I mean we could talk a
lot about more [ __ ] but let's wrap this
up shout out everything so that people
can find you all right my Instagram is
Zeta Z e da underscore Zhang zhe and G
tik-tok is just Zeta Xing
Twitter these a ting and I'm actually
gonna now that I have time and I'm not
touring as much anymore
overseas I'm gonna get back on my twitch
which is the chopstick Queen that's
[ __ ] tight that's [ __ ] tight yeah
well check her out on all that [ __ ]
thank you for sharing your story that
was [ __ ] awesome thank you
I've been through some [ __ ] that's funny
I was telling her the other day about
this one little stalker girl yeah I bet
you and your money like shut the [ __ ] up
dude I had a guy choke me out in the
bathroom because I left hair on the
floor
you [ __ ] big [ __ ] that's why I'm
saying never complain to people who have
been through more [ __ ] than you I'm over
here sound like a dumbass I'm telling
this wack ass story about how some girls
scared B she over here got choked out by
a guy that has a restraining order on
him
well thanks a lot for that anyways guys
you could catch the genius brain podcast
on all audio platforms if you see us on
iTunes give us that five stars that you
see in Spotify give us a listen put them
in your playlist stitcher whatever
audio platform out there we are in it
we'll see you all next time
perfect Oh